it's a desperately anxious wait for
these families who still search for
their loved ones every day they gather
at this makeshift morgue in Bunga lung
in western java it's where many of the
victims of the tsunami have been brought
over 100 people are still missing and
with each passing day hope fades but
these families dint give up this is the
moment the giant wave crashed through a
rock concert at a coastal resource
dozens were killed here including the
family of Willie Cisco his wife and
daughter died he almost drowned and his
son I am the only survivor my wife and
my oldest child are both dead their
bodies have been found the youngest one
is still missing they don't know where
he is either he died or he could still
be alive that's why I'm still looking
for him today I'll wait until evening
tomorrow I will be back here again to
search thousands are homeless losing
everything but they're not entirely safe
from danger yet living in overcrowded
displacement camps brings its own risk
of disease and infection I'm certain the
tsunami would bring diseases as usual
which we'll need to try and prevent it
residents evacuated from a tsunami zone
can have illnesses like diarrhea fever
coughs and colds and skin diseases for
days traumatized villages have stayed
away from their flattened homes taking
to hire safer ground too scared to
return to the sea front a tsunami
warning is still in place but battling
their fears some have started to emerge
venturing back fearfully to see if
anything of their previous lives still
remains
along this stretch of coastline down
towards the village of sumaru are some
of the worst hit areas the giant wall of
water has laid waste to entire villages
reducing homes to splinter crushing
everything in its path the destruction
here is total in some areas the damaged
roads make movement difficult bridges
have been washed away but there is a
determination from the authorities to
help this struggling community back onto
its feet the rubble is being cleared
unsafe buildings are being demolished
and power and communication lines are
being repaired and yet against all of
this there is still the uncertainty that
this nightmare is far from over
out there in the Sunda Strait is anak
Krakatau with a volcano that triggered
this tsunami and it still casts a
deathly shadow over this region
this is the third natural disaster to
hit this nation in the last five months
alone Indonesia and her people continue
to suffer so much misery simply for
existing where they do
Ashish Joshi Sky News Indonesia